cette soirée consacrée au
vieillissement voilà donc mes chers
collègues ce matin nous recevons Madame
Véronique
camaillon présidente de la 6e chambre de
la Cour des comptes il s'agit de rendre
compte de l'enquête de la Cour des
comptes sur l'agence de biomédecine que
la présidente Catherine de roche avait
demandé à la Cour en application de
l'article LO
132-3-1 du Code des juridictions
financières
j'indique que cette audition fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo
retransmise en direct sur le site du
Sénat et disponible en vidéo à la
demande je précise également aux membres
de la commission des affaires sociales
que l'enquête de la Cour des Comptes est
disponible sur démter elle ne pouvait
être rendue publique avant cette
audition ce qui est la règle madame la
Présidente je vais sans tarder vous
donner la parole afin que vous nous
présentiez les travaux et les
conclusions de la Cour des comptes et je
vous poserai ensuite les premières
questions en ma qualité de rapporteur de
la commission sur ce contrôle ensuite
l'ensemble des membres de la commission
pourra vous interroger au regard des
sujets que vous aurez présentés voilà ce
que je vous propose madame la Présidente
tout de suite c'est de vous donner la
parole pour démarrer notre édition je
vous
remercie merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur générale madame la rapporteur
de l'assurance maladie euh Mesdames et
Messieurs les les sénateurs je vous
remercie d'abord de m'avoir invité à
présenter ce rapport de la Cour dont
vous nous avez saisi sur les missions de
l'Agence de la
biomédecine puisque nous avons été
saisis vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
Président l'année dernière sur le
fondement de l'article LO 132 31 et la
cour comme vous le savez est très
attachée à sa mission constitutionnelle
d'assistance au Parlement sont présents
à mes côté donc François de la
guerronière conseiller maître et
président de section et Quentin ubi
conseiller référendire en service
extraordinaire et rapporteur de ce de ce
rapport et ils pourront être amenés à
répondre éventuellement à vos questions
après ma ma
présentation la Cour a été amenée
à examiner dans ce rapport d'une part
les conséquences de la nouvelle loi
bioéthique sur l'émission de l'Agence de
biomédecine en particulier dans le
domaine de l'assistance médicale à la
procréation et d'autre part la manière
dont l'agence exerce ses autres missions
de greffe et de prélèvement
d'organes alors vous ah oui pardon voilà
vous allez avoir le les diapositives
illustrant mon propos donc le premier
constat de la
cour c'est que les nouveaux droits
consacrés par la loi de bioéthique du 2
août 2021 dans le domaine de
l'assistance médicale à la procréation
ont conduit à un certain nombre de
tensions en premier lieu en matière de
délais assistance médicale à la
procréation en second lieu en matière de
délis et de conditions
d'autoconservation de gamette et en
troisème lieu en matière de droit
d'accès aux origines je vais reprendre
ces trois points si vous le voulez bien
les uns après les autres sur les délais
d'accès
à l'assistance médicale à la
procréation si l'ouverture au couple de
femmes et aux femmes non mariées a
répondu à un besoin réel ce nouveau
public représente désormais 90 % des
consultations réalisées dans le cadre de
la m elle a dans le même temps conduit
d'une part à la constitution d'une liste
d'attentes importantes il y a environ
5700 personnes fin 2022 qui viennent
s'ajouter à la liste d'attente relativ
au don d'ovosite environ 2100 personnes
et elle a également conduit à
l'allongement des délais d'accès pour
les assistances médicales à la
procréation tion avec don de
spermatozoïd le délai moyen est de 14
mois c'est-à-dire qu'il a augmenté de 20
% entre 2021 et
2022 et le délai moyen est de 23 mois
pour les AMP les assistances médicales à
la procréation avec Don d'ovocite au
total et ainsi que semblant témoigner
les dernières données disponibles du
Centre national des soins à l'étranger
l'ouverture à de nouveaux publics
pourrait donc à l'inverse de ce qui
était recherché par la loi de 2021
conduire un accroissement du nombre de
demandes d'assistance médicale à la
procréation faite à
l'étranger l'augmentation de cette
demande faite à l'étranger est de 26 %
depuis 2021 et concerne très
majoritairement pour mémoire l'Espagne
la République tchèque et la Belgique par
ailleurs l'arrêté du mois d'octobre 2023
relatif aux règles de bonnes pratique en
matière d'assistance médicale à la
procréation est muet totalement muet sur
les les modalités de gestion des listes
d'attentes et de prélèvement chaque
centre est donc entièrement libre de
décider des siennes aux risque
d'appréciation et de pratique
divergentes selon les territoires j'y
reviendrai tout à l'heure une telle
situation est susceptible d'avoir des
incidences non négligeable sur le projet
futur d'assistance médicale à la
procréation en conduisant par exemple à
un nombre de prélèvements d'ovosy
insuffisant du fait d'une limitation des
situations des stimulations hormonales
c'est ce que nous avons constaté puisque
certains centres limitent en dehors de
tout de tout cadre légal et
réglementaire le nombre de stimulation
hormonale alors deuxè difficulté 2ème
type de tension sur lequel je souhaite
attirer votre votre attention ce sont
les tensions liées à l'autoconservation
des gamettes les chiffres si les
chiffres témoignent d'un d'un intérêt
certains pour la nouvelle possibilité
d'autoconservation de gamett en dehors
de toute indication
médical euh cet afflux s'est traduit par
un accroissement rapide des délais qui
sont passés de 5 à 7 mois au niveau
national et pour l'Île-de-France de 13 à
24 mois euh
l'Île-de-France concentre à elle seul 25
% des demandes de consultation formulées
en France cette situation a d'ailleurs
obligé l'ARS d'île-de-fance a autorisé
de manière dérogatoire l'ouverture de
nouveaux centres afin de réduire la
pression sur les centres
franciliens troisième type de tension
c'est des tensions qui concernent le
droit d'accès aux
origines la mise en œuvre du nouveau
droit d'accès aux origines des personnes
nées d'une assistance médicale à la
procréation s'avère en effet délicate
elle est délicate d'une
part parce que le nouveau registre créé
par l'Agence de biomédecine géré pardon
par l'Agence de biomédecine ne ressens
que quelques anciens donneurs de gamette
et d'embron il y en a 54 en septembre
2023 c'est-à-dire quasiment quasiment
rien et d'autre part de nombreux centres
sont confrontés à d'importantes
difficultés pour retrouver remonter la
piste des donneurs anciens dont certains
ont été perdus de vue depuis parfois
plusieurs dizaines d'années
euh donc le le le droit d'accès aux
origines va s'exercer très différemment
selon que les les don ou les les
congelés sont
antérieures à septembre 2022 2 ou
postérieur à septembre 2022 il convient
de de souligner que le droit d'accès aux
origines donc la fin de
l'anonymat n'a pas jusqu'à présent et
contrairement aux craintes exprimées
réduit le nombre de donneurs donc ça
c'est un constat que que nous faisons à
à ce stade les choses peuvent évoluer
mais c'est un constat que nous avons
fait en revanche le droit d'accès aux
origines va avoir un impact important
sur les réserves de paillettes de
paillettes disponibles et cela à cause
de la fin programmée de l'utilisation de
l'ancien stock l'ancien stock de
gamette puisque le ministère de la Santé
a fixé au 31 mars 2025 la date qu'on
appelle de changement des cuves donc le
nouveau stock venant remplacer les
anciens
stocks et les centres de Don devront
attribuer en priorité les paillettes
congelées avant le 1er septembre 2022
pour apurer l'ancien stock et l'ancien
stock représente aujourd'hui 3/4 des
paillettes
donc selon que le stock de gamette
utilisé a été congelé avant ou après le
1er septembre 2022 la possibilité pour
les personnes nées d'une assistance
médicale à la procréation de connaître
ses origines ne sera pas la même elle
est juridiquement la même mais
pratiquement elle ne sera pas la
même au vu de ces difficultés qui
s'ajoutent au problème de l'insuffisance
de
donovocy les missions de l'Agence de
biomédecine pour encourager les don
gamette sont plus que jamais
essentielles or malgré l'attribution de
moyens supplémentaires d'environ 2
millions et demi par an les résultats
obtenus sont très insuffisants c'est en
tout cas ce dont atteste le dernier
baromètre réalisé en février
2023 18 % des personnes interrogées ont
le sentiment d'être insuffisamment
informé et 21 % ont entendu parler 21 %
seulement ont entendu parler de la
nouvelle loi de bioéthique il appartient
dès à l'agence de poursuivre et
d'amplifier ses efforts pour promouvoir
davantage le don de Gamel l'ence
l'agence pardon joue également un rôle
important concernant le contrôle de
l'utilisation des financements alloués
pour faire face au surcouts qui résulent
des nouveaux parcours d'assistance
médicale à la procréation ces surcouts
sont estimés à 7,3 million d'euros par
an les premières enquêtes réalisées ont
révélé de grandes disparités entre les
centres ainsi qu'une absence de
corrélation avéré entre les moyens dont
ils disposent et le surplu d'activité
ces enquêtes devront donc être
poursuivies afin éventuellement de
permettre une révision des des montants
c'est le cas aussi s'agissant du suivi
de l'état de santé des enfants et du
suivi de l'état de santé des femmes
ayant eu recours à la procréation
médicale assisté l'assistance à la
procréation médicale en ce domaine il
appartient en particulier à l'agence
d'élaborer le rapport annuel qui est
expressément prévu par son contrat
d'objectif et de performance euh et qui
doit suivre donc l'état des enfants nés
d'une assistance médicale à la
procréation enfin la nouvelle loi
bioéthique a confié à l'agence la tâche
de proposer des règles de répartition
des gamettes et des embryons c'est ainsi
qui a été publié en avril 2022 un arrêté
qui interdit la prise en compte de
critères discriminant à terme la Cour
estime que l'agence pourrait aller plus
loin et pourrait utilement se voir
confier une mission générale de
répartition des stocks de gamettes afin
de réduire les disparités de délis
d'accès observé entre
régions aujourd'hui l'absence de système
d'information partagé constitue à
l'évidence un frein à toute perspective
de mutualisation des stocks de gamett
venons-en maintenant si vous le voulez
bien aux missions traditionnelles de
l'Agence de biomédecine donc les greffes
et les
prélèvements
le le deuxième constat de la Cour est
que ces autres missions de l'Agence
présentent des faiblesses auxquelles il
convient de remédier s'agissant des
prélèvements et des greffes d'organes et
de tissu malgré les progrès réalisés ces
dernières années les résultats obtenus
sont décevants et les inégalités d'accès
vont croissant en particulier pour les
reins si comme le souligne le rapport de
la Cour toutes les raisons expliquant
cette situation ne relèvent pas
directement de la responsabilité de
l'agence son pilotage est perfectible à
plusieurs
égards ainsi s'agissant euh des
résultat à l'exception des objectifs
prévus en matière de donneur décédés
après arrêt circulatoire objectifs qui
sont qui sont atteints aucune des autres
cibles fixées par le plan ministériel
2017-2021 n'a été
atteinte si la chute brutale d'activité
observée en 2020 du fait de la crise
sanitaire explique en partie cette
situation le nombre de greffe d'organes
le nombre de donneurs recensés et le
nombre de prélèvements avait connu une
baisse déjà entre 2017 et 2019 ce qui
témoigne d'une situation qui était déjà
à l'époque dégradée le nouveau plan
ministériel 2022 2026 enant tirer les
leçons de ces de ces mauvais résultats
en retenant non plus des objectifs mais
de couloir de croissance donc des des
fourchettes pour ces
objectifs néanmoins on regarde des
hypothèses très optimistes qui ont été
retenues y compris pour les estimations
présentées comme basse
euh et de l'activité relevée en 2022 qui
demeure inférieure comme je vient de le
dire au niveau constaté de 2019
l'atteintte de ces objectifs nous paraît
peu probable sans une évolution
majeure alors sur des les leviers
insuffisamment exploités pour réduire le
taux d'opposition au prélèvement
d'organes en dépit d'une adhésion
majoritaire des Français au prélèvement
d'organes et de tissus le taux
d'opposition c'està-dire la proportion
de donneur recensé non prélevé par
rapport au donneurs recensés et
régulièrement supérieur à 30 % depuis 20
ans et même à 40 % dans certains
territoires donc taux d'opposition
supérieur à 40 % dans certains
territoires comme en île-de-fance
notamment et dans les dans certains
certains départements d'outremè en
Guadeloupe et en Guyane ces chiffres
sont non seulement très éloignés de
l'objectif de 25 % prévu par le plan
ministériel
2017-2021 mais ils sont en plus
sous-estimés d'environ 7 points euh par
rapport au TS réel puisqu'ils ne
prennent pas en compte les
nonprélèvements pour cause de
contre-indication médicales de tel
niveau d'opposition s'expliquent
notamment par des raisons sociétales et
par des déterminants hospitaliers en
particulier les des sous-effectifs ou le
manque de formation sur lesquels
l'Agence de biomédecine peut agir en
partie au moins la Cour estime en
particulier que la communication sur le
N d'organe pourrait être singulièrement
amélioré selon les résultats du
baromètre 2023 consacré au français au
norgane 28 % à peine des Français
interrogés connaissent les règles
applicables en matière de consentement
présumé le registre national des refus
qui joue statistiquement un rôle modeste
puisqu'il n'y a que 29000 inscrits sur
ce registre n'est plus mentionné dans
les campagne de communication de
l'agence l'Agence de biomédecine
gagnerait également à agir davantage en
direction des professionnels de santé
qui sont au contact direct avec les
donneurs potentiels et leurs famille
cela passe notamment par davantage
d'audit de coordination hospitalière
dont le nombre est inférieur aux
objectifs fixés par le plan
ministériel et davantage de formation à
l'abord anticiper des proches ce qu'on
appelle l'abord anticiper des proches
c'est bien le l'accord des proches pour
un un prél
avant le constat clinique du
décès les inégalités d'accès à la liste
nationale d'attente gérée par l'agence
perdurent en particulier pour les
greffes rénales en raison notamment des
différences de pratique des équipes
médicau-soignantes le taux d'accès à la
liste à à 24 mois est par exemple
inférieur de 40 points à la moyenne
nationale en outrem et de 20 points
inférieurs à la moyenne nationale dans
les hauts de France des recommandations
de bonne ont certes été élaboré par la
HAS mais elle reste très largement
méconnue sur le plan
quantitatif le besoin en grve d'organe a
plus que triplé en 25 ans puisqu'il est
passé de 6000 en 1998 à plus de 23000 en
2022 dont près de 90 % concern
uniquement les reins le nombre total
d'inscrits sur la liste nationale
s'élevait à fin 2022 à
[Musique]
28500 et le décès le le nombre de décès
annuels de patients en attente de greffe
à 1000 alors que l'activité de greffe l
n'a plus progressé depuis
2017 l'agence dispose de surcroix d'une
connaissance limitée des besoins à
satisfaire en matière de greffe de tissu
y compris d'ailleurs pour les greffes de
cornet qui font pourtant l'objet d'une
inscription préalable
obligatoire cette situation qui se qui
s'ajoute au problème de qualité des
gréfon prélevé et rappelons qu'un tissu
un tissu cornéen sur de n'est pas euh
n'est pas greffable et donc éliminé
faute de qualité suffisante tout cela
plaide en faveur d'une réforme du
pilotage des du réseau des banque de
tissu qui relève actuellement de
l'Agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament et des produits de santé et
qu'il serait peut-être utile de confier
à l'Agence de la
biomédecine au-delà des besoins
croissants non satisfaits la Cour a
constaté des disparité territorial qui
demeure concernant l'accès à la greffe
et en particulier à la greffe rénale par
exemple la proportion de patients
effectivement greffés 24 mois après leur
inscription est en outrem inférieur de
28 points à la moyenne nationale et dans
les Haut- de- France inférieur de 8
points à la moyenne
nationale des disparités se retrouvent
également entre établissements où les
délais d'attente peuvent dépasser 3 ans
comme c'est le cas en Île-de-France ces
disparités seraient lié selon plusieurs
associations que nous avons contacté à
la pratique dite du rein local qui
consiste à mettre en commun au niveau
national un seul des de reins prélevés
sur un donneur décédé l'autre étant
conservé par le Centre où a eu lieu le
prélèvement cette
pratique pourrait être remise en cause
mais les différents acteurs concernés ne
sont pas prêt à y renoncer
et souligne les inconvénients qu'il y
aurait à y
renoncer en dépit de leur
perfectionnement les outils utilisés par
l'agence pour
assurer une évaluation de l'activé des
équipes de greffe ne permettent pas
toujours de réagir rapidement même en
cas de dysfonctionnement grave et c'est
ce que nous avons
constaté lors de décès neuf décès
postgffe cardiaque entre janvier 2015 et
mars 2016 au CHU de Limoge et C décès
postgff constatés entre février et juin
2019 à l'hôpital enriond
d'or les agences régionales de santé ont
certes la possibilité de suspendre ou de
retirer une autorisation d'activité de
greffe suite à un avis motivé de
l'Agence de biomédecine mais cette
faculté est en réalité très peu utilisée
donc la question des seuils d'activité
se pose elle a déjà été évoquée par la
Cour elle se pose avec acuité en
particulier pour l'activité de greffe
cœur poumon et c'est une des
recommandations que nous
faisons par ailleurs sil suivi de l'état
de santé des donneurs vivants est de
plus en plus difficile à à réaliser
faute de moyens humains suffisant
l'agence pourrait publier plus
fréquemment des études sur leur qualité
de vie mission qui lui incombe depuis
2004 en ce qui concerne les greffes de
moil les activités de prélèvement et de
greffe de cellules souches
hématopoétique donc les greffes de moil
osseuses sont caractérisés par une très
forte dépendance aux registres
internationaux des marches
d'amélioration existent en particulier
avec le registre France grff de moelle
géré par l'agence et qui permet de
rechercher en temps réel les meilleurs
donneurs et les meilleurs greffons
disponibles pour une meilleure un
meilleur
appariment euh sur le plan quantitatif
si les cibles fixées par le ministère
ont été dépassées dès les premières
années d'exécution en réalité cette
situation s'explique surtout par la FA
faiblesse pardon des ambitions affichées
avec 369000 d'honneurs volontaires
recensés en 2022 le registre français ne
se classe qu'à la 16e place mondiale
loin derrière les registres américains
qui en comportte cette ,8 millions ou
allemand qui en comporte plus de 7
millions et brésilien euh des marges de
progrès existe pour réduire l'attrition
du nombre de donneurs après
préinscription ou encore pour augmenter
les capacités de réalisation des typages
génétiques c'est un un point important
le coût actuel de cette tipage est un
frein important il coûte 110 € en en
moyenne en en métropole par donneur
inscrit alors qu'il coûte 31 € en
Allemagne ces écarts s'expliquent par
les diff différence de méthodes utilisé
et rien n'empêcherait que la France
adopte les mêmes méthodes de typage que
l'Allemagne méthodes qui ont fait leur
preuve qui sont efficientes et moins
coûteuses sur le plan qualitatif des
objectifs ont été prévus pour rajeunir
masculiniser excusez-moi de cette ce
néologisme terrible et diversifier la
population inscrite sur le registre de
Greff de moelle afin de disposer de
profils plus variés euh et ces ces
objectifs sont encore très loin d'être
atteints l'agence a certes AB baissé
l'âge limite d'inscription de 50 à à 35
ans à partir du 1er janvier 2021 mais le
l'âge médian en réalité n'a pas beaucoup
bougé l'âge médian des inscrit est
supérieur à la cible de 35 ans puisqu'il
est de un peu plus de 38 ans
euh le profil des donneurs reste très
peu masculin 39 % des nouveaux inscrits
en 2022 sont des homes h et peu
diversifié puisque 36 % seulement sont
de nouveaux phénotypes et donc tout cela
à thèse de la difficulté de l'agence à
convaincre les publics ciblés donc faute
de disposer d'un registre suffisamment
large et diversifié les médecins
greffeurs sont contraints de se tourner
vers les registres internationaux
l'agence de biomédcine est donc conduite
à acheter des greffons à l'étranger en
vue de leur session aux établissements
de santé
or la proportion de greffons provenant
de donneurs étrangers au bénéfice de
patients français atteint
93,5 % soit une quasi absence
d'autonomie alors qu'elle était de 3,6 %
seulement en
1988 les donneurs allemands représentent
à eux seuls près de 60 % des des
prélèvements
réalisés pour des patients français
depuis
2018 le plan ministériel 2020 2022
pardon 2026 ent an IR remédié en fixant
un objectif de 25 % de greffons
provenant de donneurs nationaux qui
paraît peu réaliste contenu des chiffres
actuels le faible taux de couverture des
besoins n'altère pas uniquement la santé
publique mais aussi l'équilibre
financier de l'Assurance Maladie
certains registres internationaux
proposent en effet des tarifs
particulièrement élevés comme le
registre américain puisque chaque
greffon de moelle osseuse ou de s
périphérique Est factur 35000 à 40000 €
soit près du double de ce qui est
proposé en Allemagne par exemple
euh même si tous les professionnel de
santé rencontré ont indiqué qu'ils
s'orientaient à compatibilité
équivalente vers le greffon le moins
cher cette activité d'intermédiation de
l'Agence de biomédecine donc d'achat
pour cession de de greffon à l'étranger
représente à elle seul 45 % 45 % du
budget de l'agence c'est donc
considérable et elle affecte cette
activité affecte également sa logistique
comptable avec un flux de 15000 factures
à gérer par an c'est la raison pour
laquelle la cour dans ses
recommandations euh s'est attaché à
répondre à un certain nombre des
difficultés ou des dysfonctionnements
que je viens de pointer monsieur le
Président Madame la rapporteur générale
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs j'en
ai terminé donc avec la la présentation
et pour conclure je souhaiterais
insister sur les principale
recommandation que formule notre rapport
s'agissant s'agissant de l'assistance
médicale à la procréation le nécessaire
renforcement du rôle d'accompagnement et
de surveillance des principales
évolutions de la nouvelle loi bioéthique
par l'agence suppose de mettre en place
un registre national de gestion des
gamettes et des embryons afin de lui
permettre de disposer en temps réel
d'une vision consolidée au niveau
national de l'état des stocks et des
besoins de gamett c'est absolument
essentiel la Cour préconise également
d'harmoniser les règles de gestion des
listes d'attentes et les règles de
prélèvement des ovocytes en vue de leur
autoconservation en dehors de tout motif
médical tant qu'il y aura des disparités
territoriales et des disparités entre
centres les problèmes resteront
l'amélioration du pilotage de l'agence
en matière de prélèvement et de grève
d'organ et tissu implique
ensuite de lui confier le pilotage des
banques de tissu main et de fixer des
seuils d'autorisation d'activité de
greffe en particulier pour le cœur et
les poumons quant à la coordination des
activités de prélèvement et de greffe de
de cellules souches hématopoétiqu c'est
de greffe de moelle osseuse la cour
recommande d'utiliser des techniques de
typage génétique plus efficientes afin
de revoir à la hausse les objectifs de
développement quantitatif du registre
France Greff de moelle et donc
d'utiliser les techniques de typage
utilisé en Allemagne donc plus
efficiente et moins coûteuse je vous
remercie de votre attention et me tiens
à votre disposition pour répondre à vos
questions avec François la guerronière
et Quentin
ubi merci madame la Présidente pour
cette présentation et puis d'une façon
générale pour la qualité du rapport qui
nous éclaire sur beaucoup d'orientations
et lève un certain nombre de de
d'interrogations que nous avions
notamment lorsque nous avons examiné les
différents textes de loi d'actualité
alors madame la Présidente là je prendre
ma ma casquette de de
rapporteur donc de séance et donc je
vais vous présenter les les premières
interrogations et questionnements euh
tout d'abord votre rapport soulligne les
difficultés de l'agence de de la
biomédecine à assurer ses missions en
respectant les objectifs quantitatifs et
qualitatifs qui lui ont été fixés par le
dernier contrat d'objectif et de
performance et par les plans
ministériels alors nous sommes à
mi-chemin du COP 2022-2026 de l'agence
les objectifs fixés par ce C vous
paraissent-il encore atteignbles donc
c'est une question et les moyens
associés à la montée en charge des
missions de l'Agence en terme de
ressources humaines et d'infrastructure
informatique vous paraissent-il
correctement dimensionné et
employé la loi du 2 août 2021 a attribué
de nouvelles missions à l'Agence de la
biomédecine dans le champ de
l'assistance médicale à la procréation
votre rapport souligne clairement la
spécificité des missions de laabm par
rapport à ses homologues étrangers le
modè français qui est comparé confie à
une même agence un large éventail de
prérogatives vous paraît-il présenter un
intérêt des opportunités ou à l'inverse
des risques spécifiques et dans un
contexte où l'agence ne parvient pas
totalement à atteindre ses objectifs
l'octroit de ces nouvelle mission vous
paraît-elle présenter un risque de
déstabilisation de l'agence alors
qu'elle doit remédier aux insuffisances
rélevées par le report et dernière
question la liste nationale des patients
en attente de greffe ne cesse de croître
on l'a vu par vos tableaux le besoin en
greffe d'organe a plus que triplé en 25
ans alors les enjeux de qualité de
répartition des greffons prélevés
notamment Renault soulèveent deux
grandes questions d'une part celle du
modèle financier de la de l'activité de
prélèvement et de greffe mais également
celle des seil d'autorisation d'activité
déterminante pour la qualité des
transplantations vous l'avez notamment
précisé pour l'activité cœur et poumon
quel est l'état de réflexion sur ces
deux questions et si la fixation des
seuil d'activité fait l'objet d'une
recommandation de la cour dans quelle
mesure une révision du modèle financier
vous semblerait-elle pouvoir soutenir
l'activité de greffe d'organ voilà les
premières questionsame Mame présidente
euh merci monsieur le Président alors
sur les objectifs atteignable
euh la la réponse est est peut-être
peut-être double s'agissant des des
prélèvements et greffes d'organes et de
tissu
euh un certain nombre sont pratiquement
inatteignables la proportion de Grais
frénale à partir d'un donneur vivant par
exemple
euh la cible est de 20 % c'est une C qui
n'a jamais été atteinte le maximum qui
est été atteint est 16
% il nous paraît extrêmement difficile
de enfin les voilà de de les atteindre
pour répondre très clairement à votre à
votre question j'aimerais que la la la
lesffet démante le pessimisme de la cour
euh sur le nombre de Greff c'est un
petit peu le même constat c'estàdire
que
les les couloirs de croissance qui ont
été
retenus sont sont volontairement faibles
en en jusqu'en 2023 mais après la pente
est assez raide à partir de 2024 le le
l'ambition est là et qui n nous paraît
compliqué à atteindre au vu des
résultats actuels puisque
euh l'objectif euh enfin en 2023 pardon
ces 5634 grves qui ont été réalisé
c'est-à-dire le même niveau qu'en 2015
donc arver au au au couloir de
croissance tel qu'il est fixé dans les
dans le plan ministériel 2022-2026 enfin
dans le COP 2022226 n paraît extrêmement
ambitieux
euh donc voilà voilà pour les deux
objectifs en tout cas qui nous
paraissent difficilement atteignable il
y en a qui en revanche pourrait être
atteint moyennant à surcroix de
d'efforts notamment le nombre
d'établissements conventionnés la cible
est de 65 sous réserve de continuer à
signer enfin à conclure des conventions
avec ces établissements à raison de 4
par an on pourrait arriver à l'objectif
même chose pour le nombre d'audit de
coordination
hospitalière la cible est de 38 par an
on est aujourd'hui à 36 par an donc on
voit qu'on est on n pas loin ça c'était
pour les greffes d'organes et de tissus
s'agissant des des prélèvements de et
des grèves de moelle osseuses c'est un
peu la même chose il y a des objectifs
qui nous paraissent difficilement
atteignable notamment la proportion de
donneurs français pour les pour les
patients nationaux euh passé de de de
quelques pourcent à5 % enin la cible de
25 % elle n'a jamais été atteinte depuis
2003 donc on est on est aujourd'hui en
2023 donc les chiffres on a eu les
chiffres 2023 on est à 10 % de donneurs
nationaux atteindre 25 % d'ici 3 ans
nous paraît nous paraît extrêmement
ambitieux quant au taux defin à la
masculinisation excusez-moi mais du du
du registre donc le fait d'avoir plus de
donneurs
masculins c'est pareil on constate que
les les femmes représentent toujours 60
% des nouveaux
donneurs donc arrivé à arriver à
l'équilibre 50 50 qui qui font enfin qui
fait partie des objectifs nous paraît
extrêmement ambitieux pour ne pas dire
inatteignable
euh toute chose égale par ailleurs
c'est-à-dire comp tenu des des moyens
actuels et de la communication et la
promotion actuelle faite par l'agence
deux objectifs en revanche en matière de
grves de moisosseuse sont
atteignables selon nous euh sans doute
parce que les objectifs sont peu
ambitieux le nombre de nouveaux inscrits
par an euh sur le sur le registre
puisque
euh la cible est de 20000 euh est
atteinte sans difficulté et le nombre
d'inscrits totaux euh la cible de 400000
sera inscrite normalement dès sera sera
atteinte dès 2024 euh avec 2 années
d'avance donc là on est euh les les
objectifs sont atteints mais voilà la la
la réponse est un peu
un peu dual selon selon ce les
indicateurs dont on parle
euh
alors sur les moyens euh est-ce que les
moyens de l'agence sont sont
suffisants
euh il ne semble pas que les difficultés
que nous avons pointé dans le rapport
viennent d'une question de moyens qu'il
s'agisse de moyens financiers ou de
moyens humains euh h les les les moyens
ont augmenté les moyens financiers ont
augmenté les moyens humains ont augmenté
alors on a une répartition par grande
direction et et vraiment les difficultés
ne nous semblent pas provenir de de ces
moyens donc je je vais pas détailler ici
mais je pourrais vous les transmettre
l'ensemble des des des chiffres
direction par direction dans dans
l'agence il y en a un certain nombre
dans le rapport mais voilà pour répondre
très très brièvement euh
on n'est pas on n'est pas sur une
question de de moyens on attire en
revanche l'attention comme je l'ai fait
tout à l'heure sur le fait que euh plus
on arrivera à avoir des s'appuyer sur
des donneurs français et plus l'agence
pourra dégager des marges de manœuvre
financière pour un certain nombre de ses
missions alors qu'aujourd'hui 45 % de
son budget est accaparé par les achats à
l'étranger donc voilà si elle remplit
correctement ses missions elle dégage
aussi des marges de manœuvre pour euh
pour l'ensemble de de ces
missions alors sur votre votre deuxème
question
euh sur le modèle
français et
la disons la les prérogatives
extrêmement larges de l'agence comparé à
à à des des modèles étrangers ça ne nous
paraît pas être une difficulté
particulière et nous ne sommes pas
certains qu'avec avec un champ de
compéten plus réduit ou plus spécialisé
l'agence serait plus efficiente euh au
contraire d'ailleurs on appelle même
dans le rapport à à à rapatrier au sein
de l'agence une mission qui est exercée
aujourd'hui par l'Agence Nationale des
produits de santé donc
euh voilà c'est
euh
cette cette voilà palette extrêmement
large de mission ne nous semble pas
compatible avec
euh avec un bon exercice de ses missions
par par
l'agence sur
excusez-moi la question
des des listes d'attent donc du besoin
de
euh enfin des enjeux de qualité de
répartition des des greffons des
greffons avec le modèle financier que je
viens d'évoquer et puis les seuils
d'autorisation d'activité
sur les sur le modèle financier ben
c'est enfin je redis hein plus on dépend
de l'étranger et plus on ponctionne
enfin plus le budget de le de l'agence
est ponctionné et et plus on arrive à à
à s'appuyer sur des donneurs français
moins le budget de l'agence sera
sollicité et plus elle dégagera de marge
de manœuvre pour autre chose sur les
seuils d'activité alors c'est un sujet
extrêmement sensible le sujet des seils
d'AC
activité et les les médecins greffeurs
eux-mêmes sont
assez partagés et un peu réticent à
l'idée de fixer des seuils d'activité
alors ça dépend du la taille de
l'établissement dans laquel dans lequel
ils exercent dans les petits
établissements ils sont assez réticents
parce que évidemment des seuils
d'activité risqueraient de les priver
d'une activité qu'ils
exercent et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
la Cour prudemment a concentré sa
recommandation euh de fixer des seuils
d'activité sur la seule euh greffe cœur
poumon parce que c'est une greffe pour
laquelle il a été euh euh prouvé que euh
il y avait une corrélation entre les les
la qualité euh des des greffes et donc
les la mortalité consécutive au aux
greffes et euh le le seuil d'activité
donc plus euh le un centre euh un un
établissement hospitalier procède enfin
fait de des cœurs des greves pardon cœur
poumon et
moins moins il y a de de d'accidents ou
de de décès consécutif à ces greves et
plus la qualité de la de
l'intervention donne de chance au au
patients donc voilà pour les autres
organes nous ne nous nous prononçons pas
parce que manifestement la communauté
médicale elle-même est assez partagée
donc nous nous restons très prudents
mais pour cœur pour monond nous pensons
qu'il faut fixer un seuil
d'activité merci madame la Présidente je
vais donner maintenant donner la parole
à nos différents collègues et je vais
commencer par Florence
lassarade merci monsieur le président
madame la Présidente je ne sais pas si
j'ai tout entendu mais j'ai deux
questions d'une part quelles sont les
relations de l'agence avec le
l'Établissement français du sang et
est-ce que par le biais de
l'Établissement français du sang
pourrait pas améliorer la publicité
vis-à-vis des des greffes de moelle
osseusees dans la mesure où ce sont
quand même des sujets proches est-ce que
est-ce qu'il est possible d'envisager
une une amélioration de la de la
publicité faite autour des greffes de
moil osseuse j'ai une deuxième question
qui est peut-être un petit peu hors
sujet lorsque nous rencontrons les
associations de greffé du rein par
exemple on a beaucoup insisté sur
l'intérêt d'avoir des doubles blocs
opératoire c'est le prélèvement et la et
la greffe au même endroit qui évite les
les transports de les transports de de
rein qui compromettent plus plus le
transport est long et pu la la la chance
de de survie du greffon est
faible donc est-ce que l'agence de
biomécine se penche aussi sur ces sujets
là merci on va prendre plusieurs
questions je vous propose alors
maintenant qualifé
qualifé merci beaucoup madameés
présidente pour cette présentation qui
qui est très claire et qui nous qui qui
qui nous
interpelle les chiffres sont là pour en
attester durant toute ma carrière j'ai
vu j'ai vu cette
évolution de la communication et de la
technologie bien s surtout de la
communication pour les d d'organes et et
j'ai observé depuis quelques temps qu'on
a un peu baissé les bras sur la
communication alors qu'elle était
jusque- là vraiment au plus près des des
personnes dans les
associations voire même dans les
communes les petites communes et
malheureusement cet aspect là on en
entend plus parler peut-être que la
période covid a fait oublier certaines
choses mais j'ai j'ai regretté mais j'ai
peut-être pas pas bien vu qu'il n'y ait
pas un chapitre spécifique communication
dans vos recommandations ça ça c'est
vraiment la première chose il faut qu'on
soit vraiment au plus près du public
seulement pour en parler ils sont pas
obligés de se déterminer mais au moins
que les gens puissent en parler et et ça
c'était un point
positif que j'ai vécu justement dans les
années dans les années 2000
euh parce que j'ai j'ai vu cette
évolution alors il y a j'ai plusieurs
choses à à vous à vous demander euh déjà
pour les
PMO il y a certaines structures
hospitalières relativement importantes
mais pas seulement qui sont agréés pour
faire des prélèvements multiorganes et
on sait en pratique c'est que c'est pas
simple c'est pas simple bon je veux pas
faire de misérabisme hospitalier loin de
là c'est pas mon style mais au niveau
technique comment ça se passe bah on
prévient il y a un PMO qui qui arrive
donc le temps de PR de prévenir
certaines structures de Greff de
greffeur il faut que tout le monde soit
d'accord il faut que tout le monde
puisse être présent parce que certains
veulent greffer eux-mêmes leur euh
veulent prélever veulent prélever
eux-mêmes le
l'organe qu'il souhaite donc ça ça vous
bloque un bloc opératoire et toute une
équipe
opératoire au moins 12h sinon plus alors
qu'on sait que l'activité de chirurgie
en urgence est basée essentiellement sur
l'hôpital public donc ça c'est un frein
relativement important dont il faut
tenir tenir compte dans nos dans nos
réflexions et je vais
rajouter un point complémentaire vous
avez parlé de
de seuil d'activité et je le comprends
parfaitement pour le cœur poumon parce
que c'est vraiment spécifique il me
semble que pour les autres activités
l'expérience certes est importante mais
pas pas jusqu'au seuil et et le fait de
frustrer certains chirurgiens ou
d'empêcher certains chirurgiens de
greffer parce qu'ils n'ont pas le seuil
qu'il
faut je ne sais pas s'il serait c'est
humain plus qu'autre chose s'il seraiit
motivé à se battre pour faire des PR
lèvement aussi pour d'autres vous voyez
c'est c'est humain je le je le je
l'approuve pas du tout mais c'est c'est
c'est pour moi une explication alors
j'ai beaucoup d'autres questions mais je
vais les laisser pour les collègues j'en
ai une quand même sur les donneurs
étrangers vous avez dit 95 % presque de
de dépendance est-ce que on est on est
certain que ces prélèvements sont faits
avec toute l'éthique que nous
connaissons ici je parle pas de la
qualité bien sûr mais surtout de
l'éthique et et en complément est-ce que
ces donneurs sont bénévoles comme ici ou
sont
payés voilà je m pour merci beaucoup la
parole à
Olivier merci Madame la la présidente
pour la la qualité de de votre rapport
c'est peut dire que vous nous bousculez
he par rapport au aux objectifs qui sont
les nôtres vous vous nous bousculer
notamment parce que à un moment donné
mais c'est votre rôle je le salue hein
bien évidemment nous le saluons mais
vous dites à un moment donné même dans
votre réponse au aux questions du
Président si on l'Agence de biomédecine
n'atteint pas ses objectifs ça n'est pas
faute de moyens financiers et humains
alors ma question elle est la suivante
est-ce que ces fautes d'organisation où
est-ce que c'est nos principes de
bioéthique auquel on est attaché on a
discuté de la la loi il y a il y a y a
il y a maintenant quelques quel 2 ans
bon et notamment hein le le rapport
Belmont la question de la bienfaisance
de l'autonomie de la justice des droits
fondamentaux de l'altruisme la gratuité
le bénévolat tous ces principes qui sont
les
nôtres mais si on applique ces principes
et qu'en même temps on achète dans des
pays qui n'appliquent pas ces principes
alors c'est la remise en cause de notre
modèle lui-même que vous posez je veux
volontairement être iconoclasse parce
qu'on est ici pour parler en franchise
en vérité pour progresser et donc voilà
parce que quand vous dites que c'est pas
une une question de moyens humain et
financier si c'est pas une question
d'organisation alors qu'est-ce qu'on
fait merci très bien Olivier
Bernard merci monsieur le Président
d'abordi in inuction comm j'ai j'ai eu
la chance comme d'autres collègues dans
cette salle de participer un temps au
Conseil d'Orientation moi je voudrais
dire que c'est une des plus belles Agen
qu'on est l'agence de biomédecine et que
elle fait un travail qui est ce que j'ai
constaté de très grande qualité et
d'ailleurs au sein du Conseil
d'Orientation les plusieurs questions
que vous avez soulevé qui sont
fondamentales sont régulièrement débattu
je vais je vais je vais vous poser
quatre courtes questions la première
vous avez parlé par exemple de la limite
des stimulations hormonales en disant il
y a pas de cadre réglementaire c'est
vrai que c'est une question qui a enfin
moi j'ai assisté après notamment le vote
de la la dernière révision de la loi de
bioéthique à des débats sur ce sujet au
Conseil
d'Orientation la question c'est quel
cadre réglementaire faut-il qu'il est
est-ce
que un référentiel de bonnees pratique
vous paraît suffisant est-ce que vous
appelez à une réglementation d'un niveau
supérieur parce que moi j'ai constaté
que ceux qui sont confrontés à cette
situation et qui sont autour de la table
ils posent la question et donc ils
essayent de la résoudre par le consensus
en fait scientifique et social peut-être
aussi d'ailleurs mais par une forme de
consensus entre entre les acteur qui
n'est pas forcément d'ailleurs à mon
avis une mauvaise chose dans ces temps
de simplification on peut aussi
peut-être éviter d'empiler les norme
deuxièmement vous avez parlé d'une
palette trop large de mission ça tout le
monde l'a bien entendu mais quelle est
la position de la Cour c'est de de
cinder les activités d'en confier à
d'autres agences existant actuellement
de créer une nouvelle agence moi
j'aurais voulu que vous vous alliez plus
loin sur ce ce point le pardon
d'ailleurs s'il y a des répon dans votre
rapport mais comme l'a rappelé le
Président on n' pas on n' pas eu
connaissance de rapport avant cette
cette réunion et donc et pendant la
réunion moi j'ai pas lu votre rapport
voilà donc je je n'ai que les éléments
que vous nous avez présentés euh la
troisième question c'est sur les
greffes il est prévu était prévu qu'il y
ait des référents dans toutes les
agences régionales de santé pour
justement augmenter
enfin aboutir à une bonne application du
plan 2022 il y a eu trois plans au
printemps 2022 qu' on été présenté par
le ministre c'était Olivier verrant en
appliquant en déclinaison de la révision
de la loi
bioéthique dans le plan GREF il y avait
notamment cette question là est-ce que
ces référents existent et sont
optionnelle dans d' toutes les agences
régionales de santé et la 4è question
vous avez la chance j'arrive pas à me
relire donc
je je ne vous la poserai
pas merci Monsieur jaumier alors pour
terminer pour C première tournée la
parole à Véronique
Guillotin
interp
mais en tout cas voilà il y a
quelquesositions en tout cas on a des
mares et des marges de progr moi moi je
question peut-être plus technique à vous
poser j'ai pas plus tard qu'avanthier et
ça tombait plutôt bien et en
connaissance de de cette édition j'ai
été interpellé par un article sur le
monde concernant l'insuffisance rénale
chronique donc on a parlé de qui est en
fait don la greve que vous avez évoqué
le lien avec l'agence de médecine et le
traitement on va dire un des traitements
à côté des dialyses donc alors cet
article évoquait des
conduites alors
pe peucline à à respecter les bonnes
pratiques médicales dans dans certains
centres ma question est assez simple
est-ce que à côté de de la GR est un
quelque chose dont l'agence de
biomédecine soccupe est-ce que l'agence
de biomécine a un rôle de contrôle parce
que dans dans C arque il était évoqué
justement une saisie de l'agence de
biomédecine au sujet de ces
pratiquesutt en tout cas c'est ce
qualifia de mauvaise pratiques de
l'insuffisance rénale chronique donc
est-ce que l'Agence de biomédecine a un
rôle sur ces dialyses qu'elle soit
dialyses péritonéale ou dialyses à
domicide et est-ce qu'elles ont un rôle
de contrôle jou aucun rôle
concern merci beaucoup madame Présidente
je vous propose de répondre à cette
première série de questions il en aura à
peu près le même quantité pour la deè
série d'accord merci monsieur le
Président alors les les questions de
Madame la
sarade les les relations entre le
l'Agence de la biomédecine et et
l'Établissement français du sang oui il
y a des relations et il y a des
campagnes de communication qui ont été
faites en commun entre les deux agences
pour
autant les relations sont parfois
complexes entre les deux agences alors
c'est pas du tout un point qu'on a
expertisé dans notre dans notre rapport
mais euh on a contrôlé il y a quelques
années l'établissement français du sang
et on voit bien que euh il y aurait des
synergies sans doute à rechercher et qui
aujourd'hui n'existe pas
euh sur le la question du double bloc
opératoire alors on l'a pas abordé dans
le pardon
oui euh un petit peu dans le dans le
dans le passage qui concerne les
donheurs vivants mais on n'a pas on
s'est pas étendu sur cette questionl euh
qui
est qui est un qui présente un vrai
intérêt un vrai intérêt
mais voilà alors vous demandiez si si
laabm elle-même c'était pencher sur ce
sur ce sujet là et pour essayer
d'améliorer les les choses avec la la en
promouvant la pratique du double bloc
opératoire et à notre connaissance non
elle s pas prononcée là-dessus donc
alors je je rends bien compte que ma
réponse est un peu un peu frustrante ou
elliptique mais
voilà
euh monsieur monsieur califé alors la
question concernant la communication
effectivement la communication alors on
en parle dans le rapport et il y a même
une de nos recommandations qui a
trait à la communication ou plus
exactement à tout ce qui peut permettre
à l'agence de réduire les oppositions au
prélèvement et donc parmi ces outils il
y a l'outil de la communication et on
fait des développements dans le rapport
là-dessus donc c'est c'est un point
auquel on s'est intéressé parce que ça
un coup modeste c'est une question de de
volonté de
stratégie et on insiste pour dire qu'il
faut davantage communiquer faire de
vraies campagnes de sensibilisation de
communication et et et en étant très
direct en étant très direct parce que il
y a un exemple qui fait l'objet d'un
encadré dans le dans le rapport qui qui
a défrayé la la presse la chronique il y
a il y a
quelques années le l'histoire du petit
Joseph un appel d'une mère désespérée
par l'état de santé de son petit enfant
de 2 ou 3 ans atteint d'une leucémie
aigu et qui a fait une via les médias un
appel à de dons de moelle osseuse et du
jour au lendemain ou quasiment enfin
dans les semaines qui ont suivi un
afflux
considérable de propositions et de
donneurs qui se sont inscrits euh donc
on voit bien que quand on communique
alors voilà c'est un cas particulier
mais une une communication qui qui
touche les les les personnes qui qui qui
sensibilise les Français a des effets
donc la communication vous avez raison
est essentielle essentielle pour arriver
à à convaincre les Français de
s'inscrire sur le registre des des
donneurs sur le prélèvement
multiorgan vous dites c'est un un
problème de de d'organisation euh
qui qui qui voà qui qui
bloque ENF qui est à la fois peut-être
souhaitable mais qui a l'inconvénient de
bloger effectivement un bloc opératoire
au détriment d'autres opérations
urgentes mais j'avoue que là je vais
peut-être laisser la parole à notre
rapporteur s'il a des éléments à à dire
là-dessus parce que c'est un un sujetf
qu'on n pas instruit en tant que tel
dans le rapport je sais pas si peut
ajouter quel ch si si oui peut-être
juste quelques éléments évoqué alors la
difficulté essentielle du rapport c'est
qu'on traite d'mission de l'agence et
pas de la politique des des greffes en
France et en effit la difficulté majeure
et c'est quand même souligné à plusieurs
reprises dans le dans le rapport c'est
que l'agence n'a pas de prise sur les
difficultés qui sont rencontrées par
notamment les les les coordinations
hospitalières dans les structures
concernées donc néanmoins ce qu'on a
parce qu'on on allait à la rencontre de
de plusieurs coordination hospitalière
on est notamment allé à à Lille et à
Rennes ce que l'on observe c'est qu'il a
en effet des enjeux notamment de
réservation des salles opératoires il y
a des enjeux notamment de participation
des des professionnels de santé
justement dans ces dans ces réunions
visant à à libérer des places program de
de de programme donc en effet y a il y a
un enjeu véritable sur la place de la
politique en matière de prélèvement
c'est moins le cas pour la partie Greff
c'est essentiellement le cas pour la
partie prélèvement il faut bien
distinguer les deux activités il y a en
gros une activité qui est un peu
reconnue dans les établissements de
santé qui est donc l'activité de Greff
et en revanche la partie prélément qui
est pourant indispensable elle a une a
une visibilité qui est plus réduite en
revanche le rôle de l'agence en la
matière ne passe que par ce qu'on
appelle les services régionaux d'appui
qui sont qui viennent en appui par
définition à ces coordinations
hospitalières et mais néanmoins c'est de
la responsabilité des structures
l'agence elle vient en appui mais elle
ne peut pas néanmoins tout faire en la
matière et en effet donc comme c'est
souligné dès le paragraphe introductif
s'agissant du chapitre relatif au
prélément au Greff l'agence n'a pas
forcément de prix sur ces sur ces
questions là et c'est ce qui explique
aussi un certain nombre de difficultés
que l'on peut observer merci euh alors
vous aviez posé la la question aussi des
seuils d'activité enfin en tout cas vous
êtes intervenu sur les seuils
d'activité vous vous dites que
finalement la la cour dit dans son
rapport c'estàdire c'est pertinent pour
le cœur poumon pour le le reste des pour
les autres
organes il a il y a pas du tout de
consensus là-dessus et sur les donneurs
étrangers et la la question des
prélèvements
éthiques alors là on parlait bien dans
ce taux de dépendance à l'étranger des
des des dons de
moiloseuse alors non on n pas
d'information sur le fait que les
donneurs soient rémunérés ou
pas
euh avait plusieurs choses parce que ça
rejoint voilà la question qui qui avait
été posée euh sur qualité d'une part des
des greffons et d'autre part éthique eu
autour de des conditions dans lesquelles
euh les les donneurs sont amenés à
donner
euh alors sur sur la sur la euh sur la
qualité ben il y a des contrôles qualité
qui sont qui sont rigoureux et qui sont
euh qui sont effectués par euh
non seulement l'Agence de biomédecine
mais peut-être toute une une filière et
ça peut-être que Quentin peut peut
développer un petit peu sur en revanche
le enfin le bénévolat ou pas je je sèche
monsieur monsieur le sénateur et je vais
laisser Quentin qui a
peut-être sur le la partie registrees
internationaux il y a en effet une
procédure de en gros qui ressemble un
petit peu à ce qu'on peut
connaître dans le cadre de la procédure
relative à la certification Autorité de
santé à l'échelle internationale en gros
les registres internationaux sont
inscrits via une une association qui
s'appelle la wmda et derrière en fait il
y a une procédure d'accréditation qui
implique du coup le respect d'un certain
nombre de critères qualité et dès lors
que en fait on figure en fait parmi la
liste des des registres internationaux
qui sont recensés par définition on a
l'obligation de respecter un certain
nombre de critères et donc on part de ce
principe là donc c'est un enjeu ça
figure également dans le plan
ministériel 2022 2026 c'est le
renouvellement en fait de
l'accréditation du du registre France
greffe de moelle donc il y a quand même
ces contrôles qualité qui permettent
d'avoir justement à l'échelle
internationale l'assurance que les
greffons qui sont donnés aux patients
français sont de de qualité sur l'aspect
financier chaque droit en fait est
particulier et donc on vous a mis un
petit tableau avec les différents tarifs
qui sont qui sont pratiqués mais comme
c'est souligné dans le rapport notamment
les registres enfin certains registres
américains proposent des tarifs qui sont
très importants donc il y a un vrai
risque de dérive comm commercial et donc
c'est ce qui c'est ce qui nous a été dit
lorsqu'on a rencontré les les les les
médecins qui font donc des des greffes
de CSH c'est qu' en fait à qualité égale
ils ont toujours tendance à se reporter
au greffon le le le moins cher parfois
ils sont parce que il y a pas d'autres
solution dans l'obligation de prendre
des des greffons de cellules souche qui
sont particulièrement élevés par rapport
à la plupart des des registres
internationaux donc il y a en effet une
problématique qui se qui se pose dans la
matière mais en revanche on est sur du
droit international c'est chaque État
qui est libre ou non de réguler les
tarifs qui sont pratiqués par les par
les registres sachant que un bon nombre
de registres ont un caractère privéin la
spécificité du registre français
notamment par rapport à l'Allemagne on a
un encart sur le le DKMS c'est que ce
sont des registres qui sont de nature
privée tandis que le registre français
est un registre qui est donc géré par
une agence publique qui a un caractère
public alors
euh nous avons ensuite la la question de
Monsieur ho sur sur les moyens est-ce
que c'est une question de moyens une
question d'organisation ou de de
principe
bioéthique donc on a comme je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure considéré que c'était pas
les difficultés que nous avons pointé ne
sont pas une question de moyen d'évoluer
à l'agence mais bien une question
d'organisation et de choix stratégique
euh on fait un certain nombre de de
constats et et de recommandations donc
il il y a on peut être plus ENF l'agence
pourrait être plus efficace à moyen à
moyens égau par des stratégies de
communication efficace on l'a mentionné
tout à l'heure par des des audits de
coordination hospitalière qui sont
aujourd'hui en nombre insuffisant par
son implication dans une formation des
professionnels de santé amenés à agffer
et on voit que que le nombre de
professionnels de santé formés à la fois
agreffer ou aussi à accompagner les
familles pour obtenir le consentement
est très largement insuffisant donc il y
a toutes ces actions à mener qui ne
relève pas de moyens supplémentaires ni
des de principes éthique qui seraiit un
frein à telle ou telle action mais mais
vraiment de de d'organisation et de
choix
des de là où portai ses
efforts par par la l'agence sur les les
principes éthiques relatifs aux achats à
l'étranger ben je crois que la la
réponse a été a été faite par par
Quentin u
donc les question de Monsieur de
Monsieur jaumier alors la première
question sur quel cadre réglementaire
et est-ce que un référentiel de bonne
pratique suffirait ou est-ce que la Cour
appellerait à un autre alors on ne se
prononce pas sur
euh sur le type de cadre réglementaire
qu'il faudrait enfin de de ce que nous
disons c'est que on ne peut pas se
satisfaire d'une situation actuelle où
les centres ont fin finalement la main
sur les règles les modalités d'accès à
l'assistance médicale à la
procréation et donc il faut harmoniser
ces règles au niveau national pour que
les chances des des des femmes qui se
présentent soient les mêmes qu'elles
habitent Montpellier Paris ou ou ou ou
ailleurs donc peut-être que le
référentiel de bonne pratique suffit
peut-être faut-il expérimenter d'abord
cette piste avant de passer à
éventuellement si ça ne suffisait pas à
euh un texte réglementaire et en tout
cas il faut harboniser ça paraît ça
paraît essentiel sur la palette trop
large des des missions de l'Agence non
nous ne disons pas que qu'elle a des
missions trop larges elle a des missions
très larges et élargie encore depuis
2021 mais
euh nous estimons qu'elle a les besoins
elle a les les moyens d'exercer ses
missions aujourd'hui donc le fait
qu'elle ait des missions larges n'est
pas un problème en soi le fait que ces
missions soient beaucoup plus large que
certaines agences comparables à
l'étranger
euh où la la l'assistance à la
procréation et les greffes dépend de
deux organismes différents n'est pas un
problème en soi et en tout cas ça n'est
pas selon nous de là que viennent les
difficulté que rencontre l'agence à
euh notamment à atteindre les objectifs
qui ont été fixés par les pouvoirs
publics euh sur euh l'IRCT
l'insuffisance rénale chronique
terminale
euh alors c'est c'est vraiment pas le
cœur du sujet puisqu'on s'est intéressé
aux missions de de l'Agence de
biomédecine en revanche je je vous
renvoie un rapport que la la Cour avait
publié il y a quelques années donc euh
de mémoire 3 ou 4 ans sur l'insuffisance
rénale chronique terminale euh qui
euh dénonçait un certain nombre de ce
que vous avez appelé à raison de
mauvaise pratiques euh dans dans un
certain nombre de centres de dialyse euh
et qui
euh pas plus tard qu'il y a quelques
jours faisait l'objet d'un d'un grand
article du Monde me semble-t-il
euh alors le le le rôle de l'Agence de
biomédecine dans le dans dans dans
l'IRCT il est pas direct mais on peut
dire qu' elle joue un un rôle un peu
indirect dans le registre rein euh r e i
n réseau alors jeis ce que veux dire le
le le le registre plutôt
euh mais voilà c'est un c'est un un
registre qui
euh qui collationne l'ensemble des des
professionnels et qui produit des
analyses sur sur les RCT et sur la
greffe de rein donc mais en dehors de ce
rôle indirect qu'elle joue à travers le
registre
rein qu'elle qu'elle tient voilà elle
n'est pas vraiment directement en
première ligne sur sur la question de
l'IRCT voilà merci madame la Présidente
nous continuons je donne la parole à
Corina
Bert merci monsieur le Président merci
madame la Présidente pour pour votre
rapport votre exposé et et puis devant
la commission des affaires sociales
toujours très attaché aux dépenses
publiques merci de nous avoir rassuré en
nous expliquant que c'était pas une
question de moyen c'est quand même une
bonne nouvelle si je vais en retenir une
ce matin c'est c'est celle-ci euh pour
autant alors j'aurais plusieurs
plusieurs question question
remarque une qui en complément et et
sans mauvais esprit de ma part de des
remarques d'Olivier etau sur justement
les moyens financiers est-ce qu'à un
moment donné on s'est pas mis le plan
ministériel les objectifs étaient pas
très ambitieux pour justifier les moyens
qui avaient été accordés les moyens
supplémentaires en matière de ressources
humaines et moyens financiers qui
avaient été accordés à l'agence est-ce
que pour justifier cette augmentation de
moyens du coup on n' pas mis en face des
objectifs un peu trop ambitieux comme si
on mettait un petit peu la la la charrue
avant les bœufs la communication et vous
l'avez très bien dit étant essentielle
pour lever les les freins au au
prélèvement ça c'est c'est une remarque
en tout cas c'est une interrogation de
ma part parce qu'il faut qu'on on soit
sur des objectifs réalistes
euh peut-être quelque chose qui manque
dans votre rapport mais c'était
peut-être pas dans votre mission euh
concernant les prélèvements et et les
Greff c'était en face le taux d'activité
des équipes de Greff dans les hôpitaux
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
est-ce que est-ce
que on parle beaucoup des difficultés de
l'hôpital est-ce que les je je met cette
question en parallèle parce qu'elle me
paraît quand même essentielle parce
qu'il y a pas de greffe sans sans
médecins qui les réaliseent est-ce que
les services de prélèvement et de
greffes sont préservé des difficultés de
l'hôpital et quel est leur taux
d'activité alors encore une fois c'était
peut-être pas dans votre mission mais je
trouve ça serait intéressant de le
mettre en rapport avec la la diminution
en tout cas les les écarts entre les
objec et et et ce qui est ce qui est
réalisé
euh sur la MP sur la M donc vous l'avez
souligné dès le début de de votre
rapport sur l'allongement des délais
d'attente he pour l'accès à la première
consultation depuis la la loi de
bioéthique de
2021 cette hausse qui donc priori
n'avait pas été anticip dans telle
proportion mais donc sousension les
structures alors je vais poser une
question peut-être
qui peut fâcher choquer mais ça fait
rien je vais la poser est-ce que pour
garantir un meilleur accès à ce nouveau
droit l'ouverture à de l'activité à des
structures privées lucratives sous
réserve bien sûr de de tarif encadrés
vous paraît-elle une solution ou pas
j'ai pas j'ai pas d'appriori hein mais
parce que je me mets aussi à la place de
de ces femmes et cetera qui qui sont
dans l'attente est-ce que alors j'ai vu
un chiffre de 7li3 mais je sais
pas quel était ce qu' ce qu'ilenglobait
est-ce que vous avez pu établir un bilan
du coup de de la réforme de l'accè
ouvrant l'accès à la M aux femmes en
couple et et aux femmes aux femmes seul
et enfin peut-être une dernière question
le terme de démocratie sanitaire est
absent de votre rapport comment
pensez-vous que l'agence devrait se
positionner en la matière et quelque
part est-ce que ça aiderait à mieux
parler de la chance qui même si elle est
créée depuis 20 ans en fait paraît
encore trop méconnu de la part du grand
public et même parfois puisque si je
l'ai bien compris vous partagez cette
même parfois des professionnels de santé
je vous remercie merci Madame la
rapporteur la parole à Nick
Pétrus merci monsieur le président
madame la Présidente merci pour votre
présentation très complète vous l'avez
dit le plan
2017-2021 n'a pas atteint ses
objectifs la difficulté ne réside ni
dans les moyens financiers ni dans les
moyens humains donc ser une question de
méthode de réglementation d'éthique quoi
qu'il en soit ma question est la
suivante euh l'importation des gamettes
est autorisée en France mais dans des
conditions extrêmement strictes elle est
en effet soumise à l'autorisation de
l'Agence de la biomédecine et doit être
effectuée dans des conditions
expressément prévues par le code de la
santé publique notamment pour la
poursuite d'un projet parental précis
pensez-vous qu'un assouplissement de ces
règles pourrait nous aider à
reconstituer plus rapidement nos
stocks merci pour cette question la
parole Anne
souris merci monsieur le Président c'est
une c'est une question qui va dans dans
la ligne de ce que pose madame Humbert
puisque les chiffres de 2023 de l'Agence
de biomédecine signal un allongement
préoccupant des délais d'attente qui
atteignent désormais 16 mois pour les
dones de spermatozoïdes et 24 mois je
parle de la PMA évidemment pour les
dones d'ovocy je souhaite donc vous
questionner sur les mesures que l'Agence
de la biomédecine pour assurer un réel
accès à la PMA notamment avec
l'ouverture de la PMA au couple de
femmes et aux femmes seules cette
situation est particulièrement
problématique pour ces femmes auxquelles
on avait promis de pouvoir fonder une
famille lors de la loi de bioéthique de
2021 quelles sont donc les réponse que
vous pouvez apporter pour améliorer
cette situation sur la disponibilité des
gamettes
merci merci beaucoup la parole à Annie
louirou merci monsieur le Président ma
première question rejoint celle qui
vient d'être posée la loi de bioéthique
2021 donc a autorisé l'aut
l'autoconservation des gamettes euh pour
les femmes de 29 à 37 ans euh seul 41
centres sur les 104 centres d'AMP donc
français sont autorisés euh euh
à à pratiquer euh donc ces cette
autoconservation euh est-ce que vous
pouvez nous éclairer sur
euh euh ces chiffres pourquoi seulement
41 centres sur 104 j'ai pu lire que
certaines direction évoque le fait que
cette activité ne serait pas rentable
alors que il y
a un nombre important de femmes en
attente et on peut considérer que à
partir de 35 ans alors que le droit à
cette autoconservation va jusqu'à 39 ans
en réalité à partir de 35 ans les femmes
n'y ont pu accès donc est-ce que vous
avez des préconisations des mesures
transitoires à à recommander pour faire
en sorte que le droit de ces de ces
femmes puissent être puissent être servi
et puis ma deuxième question concerne la
communication autour des des dons de
d'organes vous constatez une évolution
très timide des donneurs surtout des
donneurs d'ailleurs plus que des
donneuses est-ce qu'on on peut faire une
est-ce que vous avez pu faire une
évaluation de ces communications il y a
beaucoup de maires qui sont engagés en
fait pour promouvoir ces dons d'organes
mais ne faudrait-il pas élargir plus
largement ces ces ces campagnes
nationales en fait autour des
entreprises des administrations pour
faire en sorte que les donneurs soient
plus nombreux et donc qu'on puisse
accéder euh pour les personnes qui en
ont le besoin donc à à ces traitement
merci merci la parole à Sylvana Sylvan
alors merci monsieur le Président
d'abord merci pour ce ce rapport précis
extrêmement éclairant
euh il y a
eu un grand nombre de questions donc je
je vais prendre en compte le fait qu'on
a eu à la fois des questions et des
éléments de réponse donc je vais me
faire le le plaisir pour le coup de
poser une question ni médicale ni
technique ni
réglementaire j'ai été étonné
particulièrement par le le le taux de de
refus qui vous le disiez tout à l'heure
sur certains territoires dépasse 40 % on
ajoute 7 points on est quasiment voilà
on aondit ça fait quasiment la la moitié
la moitié de la population
euh ce taux de
refus qui me paraît être un un levier
important hein
puisque augmenter le nombre de donneurs
entraîne la possibilité effectivement
d'avoir des dons et d'augmenter la marge
de manœuvre donc c'est ma question elle
va elle va aller dans ce sens-là
euh est-ce que vous avez alors je vous
je je comprendrai si vous me dites que
ça fait pas ni partie du rapport ni de
vos attributs tion mais à un moment
donné c'est intéressant de savoir à quel
endroit ça se passe est-ce que vous avez
des éléments sur la façon dont on prend
en compte le fait que le don d'organe
est une question éminemment intime
personnelle voire culturel et
que on sait depuis longtemps que dans
ces domaines là l'information et la
communication sont de
d'assez ont un impact assez assez c'est
réduit donc est-ce qu'on a des éléments
sur la façon dont on travaille cette
question là en complément de cette
question je me demandais si vous avez
des éléments sur le fait que à un moment
donné le don était un acte volontaire
aujourd'hui l'acte volontaire c'est le
refus du don est-ce que cette inversion
du rapport au don parce que c'est de ça
dont il s'agit est-ce qu'on a des des
données des éléments sur l'IMPA impact
que ça a eu sur le don parce
que je je fais partie de ceux qui qui ne
souhaitent pas tout mettre sur le dos du
covid par rapport à à ce qui peut
évoluer et je je m'arrêterai là sur les
questions et je me permettrai d' de
faire une remarque je persiste et c'est
pas une remarque naïve à ne pas
comprendre pourquoi on se fixe des
objectifs dont on sait qu'ils sont
able très bien et pour terminer la
parole à Madame lance
müerbron merci madame la Présidente pour
toutes les informations que vous venez
de nous apporter qui qui sont
inquiétantes par moment bien sûr alors
moi je voulais poser une question sur
une question un petit peu tabou je crois
sur le tourisme de transplantation euh
quel est son impact sur l'accès aux
soins pour les malades qui sont soumis
au nom de la la solidarité nationale au
principe de consentement alors vous avez
exprimé qu'il y a des listes d'attentes
qui sont différentes selon les les
territoire moi je viens du barrain donc
frontière allemande et en fait nous
avons des des des des temps d'attente
pour les greffes qui sont très longs
fait partie des plus longs grand test
mais Strasbourg Nancy mes euh puisque
nous faisons face à à en fait le dépôt
par des filières
étrangères de de malades qui viennent
donc des pays de l'Est des
ressortissants qui arrivent en en état
d'urgence et qui sont donc prioritaires
dans les centres de dialyse l'Allemagne
a une politique qui ne prend en charge
les dialysés que pendant 15 jours et
ensuite elle les amène à la frontière
donc les
hôpitaux de Strasbourg hein connaissent
cette difficulté mais au-delà de ça
quelle est la quelle piste pour mieux
encadrer les bénéficiaires et comment
aborde-t-on ce je dis bien entre
guillemets ce tourisme de
transplantation qui est vraiment
important et qui ralentit l'accès à la
greffe pour la les les les français bien
sûr mais qui le souvent le le don c'est
au nom de la solidarité nationale c'est
le principe d'un consentement présumé
qui a été choisi et et là ça peut
peut-être expliquer les refus dont vous
venez de parler merci
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente je
vous laisse la parole merci monsieur le
Président alors questions nombreuses sur
la question de Madame Himbert alors vous
posez la question de savoir si
finalement les objectifs peu ambitieux
qui ont été fixés à l'agence n'ont pas
été fixé justement à dessin de manière
peu ambitieuse pour justifier des moyens
insuffisants alors c'est pas du tout la
lecture que la Cour fait de de la
chose les objectifs sont peu
ambitieux mais et peut-être aussi pour
donner une chance à l'agence de les
atteindre
euh mais c'est pas à mettre en en
relation avec avec les moyens et
peut-être pour pas désespérer
complètement l'agence puisqu'on sait que
c'est ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure en
répondant à la question de monsieur le
Président un certain nombre d'objectifs
sont sans doute inatteignables
euh sur le le taux des des activités le
taux d'activité pardon des des équipes
de Greff
euh et sur le fait que les les services
enfin dans quelle mesure les les les
services de grève peuvent être atteints
par les disfonctionnement ou les
difficultés disons de de l'hôpital alors
on n' pas regardé ce ce point-là en
particulier donc moi je n'ai pas de
réponse à vous faire je est-ce que c'est
un service enfin ce sont des services
qui souffrent moins ou plus de la
désorganisation à l'hôpital de
l'insuffisance de de moyens humains
alors souvent je n'ai pas la réponse à à
la question euh il y a pas de raison
qu'ils échappent à aux tensions qu'on
observe dans tous les autres services
euh sur le sujet sensible de l'ouverture
au privés lucratifs on dira est-ce que
ça n'est pas une solution finalement
pour essayer de régler une partie des
problèmes de délai d'attente
euh
alors le débat n'est pas tabou euh et un
groupe de travail au sein de la BM se
penche sur cette questionl euh donc le
débat n'est pas tabou et
euh des avancé ont été enfin des
propositions ont été avancées qui
consisteraiit à proposer de déléguer au
privé enfin de confier au privés un
certain nombre de tâches àont euh
notamment les premiers examens
nécessitai par par les le fait de
s'inscrire dans un une démarche de de de
procréation les les l'ouverture des
dossiers administratifs et cetera donc
voilà les les choses bougent
euh effectivement cette aide qui serait
plus logistique dans un premier temps
plus réalisation de premiers examens
pourrait permettre de désengorger les
les centres et de réduire les délais
d'attente est-ce qu'il faut aller plus
loin je suis pas sûr que la réponse
appartienne à la cour mais peut-être que
donc le résultat de ce groupe de
travail sera connu mi 2024
donc voilà dans dans quelques mois on
aura un éclairage un peu plus un peu
plus
autorisé sur la démocratie sanitaire
alors effectivement le mot est absent du
rapport mais pas mais pas le le le
concept lui-même
puisque à travers un certain nombre de
de points qui sont évoqués dans le dans
le rapport de fait nous évoquons la
démocratie
sanitaire quand on quand on parle du
comité de suivi des principales
innovations qui associe des
représentants d'association
d'institution de société savant et
cetera on est dedans quand on parle des
différents groupes de travail qui font
intervenir des associations de patients
on est dedans aussi et on voit que la
démocratie sanitaire
est est importante hein sur ces
questions la la préparation des plans
ministériels se fait également avec
l'appui des représentants des usagers
lors des concertations préparatoires
donc ça la démocratie sanire n'est pas
absente de notre rapport n'est pas
absente de ces questionsl
euh quand elles sont quand elles sont
traitées elles associent bien les
représentants des des patients
euh voilà je crois que j'ai
répondu
sur question de Madame
pétrusus sur voilà sur l'importation des
gamettes la la la question de Madame
Pétrus euh
oui on revient toujours un petit peu à
la question de la la la communication
c'estàdire que les les stocks de
gamettes bah ils sont directement liés
au nombre de donneurs et le nombre de
donneurs est directement lié au au à la
capacité qu'a la société française dans
son ensemble et puis évidemment l'Agence
de biomédecine au premier chef de
convaincre les Français de euh de de
donner
donc et puis
euh sur les sur les oui ben donc on en
revient encore une fois au aux questions
de communication il y a un vrai sujet de
communication pour arriver à à
convaincre
euh les les Français de de donneré
euh sur la question
[Musique]
des des délais
euh donc c'était la question
de Madame souris je crois la question
des délai et le fait de d'assurer un
réel accès à la PMA je n'ai pas de
réponse nous avons constaté dans le dans
le rapport cette cette difficulté ces
délais qui s'accroissent alors même que
l'objectif de la loi était de au
contraire de de de
faciliter notamment l'accès à la à
l'assistance médicale à la procréation
on constate qu'aujourd'hui les objectifs
sont loin d'être atteints euh comment
assurer un réel accès ben c'est un
certain nombre des recommandations que
nous faisons c'est-à-dire à la fois bien
sûr la communication mais
aussi peut-être
davantage de centrre
[Musique]
euh et puis euh
euh qu'est-ce que nous
avons voilà et puis effectivement de de
de confier peut-être au privés un
certain nombre de tâches qui aujourd'hui
embolisent un peu les centres et qui
sont des tâches plus administrativ ou de
préparation enfin des premiers examens à
la préparation de ce qui va suivre donc
ça peut-être aussi une une une un début
de
réponse alors sur la question de Madame
erou sur la l'autoconservation des des
gamettes pourquoi seulement 41 centres
ont été autorisés alors ça c'est la la
situation
aujourd'hui est-ce que d'autres devrai
être autorisé dans les dans les
prochaines
années mais à quel rythme est-ce qu'on a
une idée du nombre de centres qui vont
être autorisés et des des dossiers qui
sont instruits actuellement dans ce sens
je laisse Quentin ubi répondre oui il y
a un enjeu en fait en terme de
d'autorisation
puisque à titre dérogatoire en fait un
certain nombre de centres AMP en fait
ont été autorisés à réaliser l'activité
de d'autoconservation pour maison pour
raisons non médicales et par contre du
coup à l'issue des des des nouveaux
projets régionaux de de santé il y aura
du coup une une
enfin une autorisation d'activité qui
sera séparée et donc il y a néanmoins un
projet visant à développer cette
activité donc par contre du coup le
chiffre que vous évoquez là nous on l'a
pas forcément obtenu le le fait qu'il y
ait un nombre important de centres qui
étent autoris si j'ai bien compris c'est
il y a un nombre important de centres
qui sont autorisés qui ne qui ne font
pas de l'activité ou ou ce sont des
centres qui ne sont pas
autorisés c'est deux c'est deux sujets
différents du coup puisque dans le
premier cas c'est le fait que des
centres disposant de l'autorisation
it parce que vous avez voilà vous avez
évoqué le cûtz
oui ce sont des centres qui pourraient
développer cette activité mais qui ne le
font pas parce que ça ne rapporte pas en
fait il ne couvrent pas leur leur leurs
charges très bien je je permets
d'insister mais c'est il y a deux pour
moi situation c'est soit le centre a
l'autorisation et dans ce cas à ma
connaissance tous les centres qui sont
autorisés le font soit ils n'ont pas
l'autorisation ça pour moi les raisons
les les raisons financières sont
réduites dans la mesure où en fait il y
a une prise en charge par l'Assurance
Maladie de l'autoconservation comme on
l'indique dans le dans le rapport en
principe c'est couvert les frais qui
sont associés à la réalisation de
l'autoconservation pour motifs non
médical sont couverts par l'assurance
maladie la seule chose qui reste à la
charge des des patients c'est en gros un
forfait annuel et donc les le fait que
ça ça ne soit pas rentable en tout cas
nous on l'a pas on l'a pas identifié
comme problématique merci Quentin et
alors la la deuxème de de de vos
questions concerernent oui les
communication sur le nom d'organe on est
d'accord on a déjà répondu et on répond
dans le rapport oui bien sûr c'est un
c'est un vrai sujet
euh sur
euh
euh madame Silvani euh madame Sylvanie
vous vous avez posé la question du
interpellé que vous étiez par le le la
le taux de refus très important entre 30
et et 40 % selon selon les régions euh
euh et et vous dites finalement
aujourd'hui c'est le refus qui est un
acte volontaire est-ce qu'il faut pas
inverser inverser les les choses B il y
a un peu deux écoles en la matière il y
a l'école allemande j'allais dire
puisque en Allemagne c'est le cas c'est
l'acceptation explicite et puis il y a
le cas de la France où c'est
l'acceptation
implicite alors
euh ce qu'on remarque
euh c'est que
aujourd'hui en l'état des données dont
on dispose les résultats du deuxème
modèle c'est l'acceptation implicite
comme comme ce qui se passe en France
donne de meilleurs résultats en terme de
Don alors c'est peut-être pas vrai pour
la France mais c'est vrai pour d'autres
pays qui ont cette même cette même
politique mais à condition de laisser
une marge de manœuvre aux familles comme
c'est le cas d'ailleurs comme c'est le
cas en France puisque les familles en
dépit du fait que l'acceptation est
censé être être accepté enfin être cé
censé être être là dès lors qu'il n'y a
pas eu de refus en réalité les équipes
médical de Greff se tourne
systématiquement vers les familles et
c'est là qu'on a aussi un taux de refus
extrêmement important
euh donc voilà encore une fois je pense
que puisque ça marche dans d'autres pays
qui ont la même le même système que nous
il y a pas de raison que ça ne marche
pas en France et que il faut mieux
communiquer mieux expliquer fairec
beaucoup d'effort de pédagogie et mieux
former aussi les équipes médicales à
convaincre les familles de laisser faire
ce le prélèvement
d'organ sur sur les décès en particulier
sur les décédés
[Musique]
euh sur
le le tourisme ben je peut-être te
laisser répondre si tu le si tu le
souhaites sur le tourisme médical euh
alors pas seulement entre la France et
l'Allemagne mais euh oui alors vous avez
évoqué en effet des des durées d'attente
qui sont qui sont très longues euh dans
le dans la région Grand Est alors
sachant qu'il y a des disparités
également entre entre établissements on
a essayé de de faire un petit peu sur la
base des données de l'agence un peu une
cartographie en 2022 des des délais avec
il y avait un graphique avec derrière un
certain nombre d'établissements où les
délais sont très courts et notamment
c'est le cas en Île-de-France où des
délais sont sont très longs mais c'est
le cas aussi dans certaines structures
NOTAM
dans le grand test il y a un certain
nombre de réponses qui ont été qui ont
été apporté par par l'agence pour
essayer de de contrecarrer un petit peu
ces ces difficultés c'est notamment la
question des des scores de de
répartition des greffons et en
particulier Renault où on a donc du coup
mis en place des outils qui permettent
avec des critères objectifs d'essayer
d'améliorer cette cette répartition
néanmoins il y a des s'agissant du du du
tourisme médical en tant que tel un un
principe de réalité c'est que les en
principe les gens sont libres de choisir
le centre pour justement en fonction de
de la connaissance des meilleurs
résultats de tel ou tel sentre sont
libres en fait d'aller se faire inscrire
pour obtenir donc leur accès à la liste
nationale d'inscription dans
l'établissement de leur choix ce qui
fait que même si on essaie de mettre en
place un certain nombre de de de gardes
fous et on a essayé notamment s'agissant
d'escors d'attribution de montrer un peu
les limites actuelles de ce dispositif
puisqueil y a un enjeu notamment sur
l'île-de-fance avec un modèle
géographique qui appelle un certain
nombre de réserves de notre part en
revanche les citoyens sont totalement
libres de choisir le le centre pour se
faire inscrire donc c'est une des
difficultés à laquelle il est difficile
même en mettant des outils de de
répartition avec du coup ces ces scores
et en particulier pour le pour le RIN
pourrait pas empêcher un un citoyen
d'aller regarder le rapport de l'Agence
de savoir où trouver l'information sur
la
durée en ce sens il y a des difficultés
pour encadrer ce tourisme ce tourisme
d'accès à la greffe mais les outils en
tant Queel vous avezqué des
problématiques liées au aux questions
transfrontalières c'est pas des éléments
forcément sur lesquels on a on a
instruit des des éléments mais de fait
les outils de l'agence qui ont vocation
y répondre c'est ca en tout
cas excusez-moi une question à laquelle
je n'avais pas répondu qui avait été
posée par
madamebert sur est-ce qu'on dispose d'un
bilan de l'application de la loi
finalement sur le nombre de seul ou
nombre de femmes en couple qui ont
recours à à une assistance médicale à la
procréation alors je crois qu'on dispose
pas de de de chiffres
précis en tout cas on ne peut pas poser
évidemment la question de l'orientation
sexuelle des femmes qui se
présentent à à la à la
MP
pardon au total ah oui
euh
ça oui ouiy ou peut-être juste c'était
cétait en fait l'ouverture de ce nouveau
droit aux femmes en couple ou aux femmes
seules le coût financier pour de ce
nouveau droit en fait j'ai j'ai vu un
chif dans votre rapport le 7,3 million
d'euros mais je sais pas ce que ça
englobe en fait donc je sais pas c'était
ça ou c'était en rapport autre chose
voilà oui oui oui c'était ça absolument
voilà mais je croyais que vous demandiez
le le la répartition et celle-là on
pasile de finan question voilà
TR bien Madame la Présidente nous allons
clôturer notre audition et un grand
merci alors merci à la cour pour la
qualité des travaux on a toujours
beaucoup de plaisir à vous entendre ici
en commission et merci pour les les les
réponses qui ont éclairé en tous les cas
le débat les réflexions voilà donc un
grand merci puis c'est j'aurais tendance
à dire c'est un sujet à suivre en tous
les cas hein voilà merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup très bien et on se reverra sur
la santé respiratoire c'est
ça
qu